allora buona sera io mi trovo qua in
questo non so come chiamarlo tempio di
bellezza con l'ingrato compito invece di
trattare una maniera una maniera spero
scientificamente adeguata una materia
che invece piuttosto pil e
repellente ed è appunto è stato già
detto la corruzione
ora non la corruzione dei corpi neanche
la corruzione dei frigoriferi ad opera
dei tostapane di cui ho scoperto
l'esistenza oggi ma molto più
semplicemente la corruzione delle
coscienze che è la premessa perché poi
si abbia corruzione nella politica
nell'economia nell'amministrazione della
cosa pubblica
questa è la rappresentazione che ne da
lorenzetti nel palazzo pubblico di siena
l'allegoria del cattivo governo e questo
è l'identikit del politico corrotto del
governante corrotto dell'epoca e
naturalmente
ognuno vi trovi
somiglianze con chi crede penso che ce
ne sia più d'una
premetto io troverò a trattare appunto
un tema che inevitabilmente getterà una
luce piuttosto inquietante sul nostro
paese
e allora vorrei esordire con una nota
per così dire ottimistica nonostante la
corruzione o forse proprio grazie alla
corruzione e l'italia è un paese di
straordinarie opportunità è la cosa più
incredibile è che questa opportunità
spesso si presentano all'insaputa dei
beneficiari
qualche esempio non v'è paese al mondo
in cui qualcuno si trovi pagata a sua
insaputa una casa con vista colosseo
vacanza in un resort da mille euro a
notte
ristrutturazione di villa
un paese delle meraviglie
naturalmente c'è un anonimo beneficiario
che non chiede nulla in cambio e in
questo paese è capitato persino che dei
politici in erba che poi saranno la
futura classe dirigente di questo paese
si siano scoperti laureati in
prestigiose università albanesi laureati
in tempi record a conferma diciamo delle
loro doti intellettuali ma
misteriosamente anch'essi laurati
laureati a loro insaputa
allora queste opportunità non discendono
da un colpo di fortuna bisogna sapersela
meritare
occorre una lunga gavetta lavorare sodo
di solito lavorare nell'ombra
e soprattutto trovarsi nel posto giusto
al momento giusto avendo come dire in
tessuto le relazioni che contano nella
corruzione è il caso di dirlo esiste una
meritocrazia come in pochi altri settori
della vita pubblica italiana
purtroppo è una meritocrazia alla
rovescia che premia inevitabilmente i
peggiori quelle più abili come dire nei
maneggi sottobanco quelli disposti anche
a chiudere un occhio e meglio se tutti e
due di fronte al disastro collettivo che
è prodotto appunto dall'azione di tanti
privilegiati a loro insaputa e poi c'è
da dire che purtroppo la corruzione
anche delle vittime e queste sono
vittime veramente a loro insaputa sono
vittime della corruzione i cittadini che
pagano le opere pubbliche prezzi
esorbitanti
spesso opere pubbliche inutili o mai
realizzate
dietro questo pre pubbliche il caso di
dirlo ci sono soltanto gli interessi
convergenti dei corrotti e dei
corruttori in alcuni casi la
corruzione ha delle vittime ben
identificabili che hanno un nome e un
cognome e allora noi abbiamo casi di
ammalati che muoiono perché si sono
visti trapiantate valvole cardiache
difettose e la ragione che la casa
produttrice offerto alla tangente più
alta al chirurgo funzionari onesti che
sono trucidati dai sicari mafiosi operai
soffocati in una cisterna anche se
c'erano stati i controlli degli
ispettori poco tempo prima
però il controllo era stato pilotato in
cambio di una mazzetta
questa è una statistica che mostra come
vi sia una correlazione molto forte tra
le morti bianche le morti sul lavoro
e i livelli di corruzione nelle regioni
italiane
tutti questi esempi a scanso di equivoci
sono tratti appunto dalla cronaca
italiana però se ci fermiamo la
superficie
guardiamo ad esempio le statistiche
giudiziarie la corruzione
miracolosamente in italia diventa un
problema di poco conto pochi casi per
giunta che sono in diminuzione negli
ultimi anni
il fatto è che la corruzione è un
fenomeno che tende a restare oscuro
anzi io direi con una citazione colta
mirabilmente oscuro come
dante alighieri descrive la bolgia nel
ventunesimo canto dell'inferno in cui
sono sprofondati appunto i corrotti
dell'epoca come vedete soggetti una
sanzione un po più severa di quella
prevista anche nel disegno di legge
anticorruzione che oggi si discute di
cui oggi si discute corrotti e
corruttori naturalmente operano
nell'ombra non ci sono testimoni
e proprio quando non affiora in
superficie la corruzione diventa più
pericolosa perché si sviluppa appunto in
modo sotterraneo e quindi indisturbata
non non ci si pone il problema di
contrastarla
invece da qualunque parte la si guardi o
meglio se si utilizzano indicatori più
efficaci
la corruzione italiana
rappresenta un'anomalia l'anomalia di un
paese che ha un'economia avanzata
istituzioni liberaldemocratiche
uno stato di diritto robusto ma che
nonostante questo presenta livelli di
corruzione percepita sulla base
dell'indicatore di transparency
international che il più attendibile in
questo senso che sono superiori a quelle
di molti paesi in via di sviluppo
d'italia il rosso misura la febbre della
corruzione all'italia quella macchia
rossa in mezzo al mediterraneo caso mai
avesse dei dubbi ecco l'italia al
69esimo posto su 182 paesi considerati
siamo considerati al pari del ghana e
della macedonia però più corrotti di
turchia cuba namibia ruanda quartultimi
in europa e se dalle percezioni passiamo
alle esperienze concrete il quadro non
cambia 2011 12 per cento dei cittadini
italiani si è visto chiedere una
tangente il che è il segno che questo
fenomeno non interessa più come dire
grandi appalti le grandi speculazioni
immobiliari ma entrato ormai nella vita
quotidiana di milioni di nostri
concittadini e presumibilmente anche di
molti di noi alla di fronte a questo
quadro un po allarmante vorrei dire la
risposta di chi fa ricerca è come dire
la speranza nella conoscenza se abbiamo
delle teorie che ci aiutano a spiegare
le ragioni di questa diffusione
capillare del fenomeno allora possiamo
anche comprendere com'è che si riproduce
attraverso quali meccanismi e magari
avere delle idee che ci possano aiutare
a disegnare degli efficaci strumenti di
prevenzione e di contrasto
allora vediamole queste teorie
l'approccio economico che è dominante ci
dice sostanzialmente che la corruzione è
presente laddove conviene i corrotti e
corruttori potenziali mettono sui due
piatti della bilancia i vantaggi costi
attesi e decidono se è il caso di
proporre accettare una tangente c'è
persino la formula della corruzione una
specie di formula magica che ci dice
sostanzialmente che la corruzione amenta
quante più risorse allo stato amministra
quanto più ampi sono i poteri
discrezionali di funzionari e ridotti i
controlli sul loro operato e
naturalmente la trasparenza della
gestione
ecco se applichiamo questa formula della
corruzione al caso italiano
se arriva una conclusione sconfortante
perché in italia con la corruzione si
può guadagnare molto anzi moltissimo e
si rischia poco anzi quasi nulla
cominciamo con la prima variabile che
lega la corruzione a quanti soldi
pubblici i funzionari spendono diciamo
infischiandosene dei prezzi di mercato
e allora il caso è quello noto di opere
pubbliche molte opere pubbliche che
costano 2 3 volte nel caso della tav ha
addirittura sei volte tanto per costo al
chilometro di un equivalente
realizzazione in francia spagna e
giappone c'è il caso del passante
ferroviario di milano che è costato il
doppio di quello di zurigo però in
compenso abbiamo impiegato il doppio del
tempo nel realizzarlo
se si farà la tav torino lione a mio
avviso la prossima probabile grande
mangiatoia di stato sarà interessante
confrontare il costo unitario di
realizzazione della stessa galleria che
fora il medesimo monte la medesima
montagna presumo che ci saranno delle
differenze e accetto scommesse su quale
sia il versante sul quale costano di più
poi la corruzione più probabile quanto
più i politici ei funzionari hanno la
possibilità di decidere
discrezionalmente chi si vede assegnati
quei benefici e allora pensiamo alla
moltiplicazione di strutture speciali
sul modello protezione civile per
intenderci che poi si rivelano
immancabilmente presidiate da cricche
varie comitati d'affari in cui negli
ultimi anni sono stati affidati in
deroga ogni regola la gestione
centinaia di appalti migliaia di appalti
anche di grande spessore in italia siamo
riusciti a gestire con procedure di
emergenza anche venti che erano
prevedibili da secoli e memorabile il
caso delle celebrazioni colombiadi che
erano attese da almeno 500 anni
cinque secoli e che sono state le opere
connesse a quelle celebrazioni gestite
come se fossero arrivati all'improvviso
in attesa e quindi criteri straordinari
il problema è che appunto come mostra
questa slide
la discrezionalità nasce anche di fatto
quando un funzionario proprio per i
ritardi cronici dei suoi uffici può
decidere come dire discrezionalmente
quale pratica lasciare su un tavolo a
prendere polvere quale invece accelerare
quindi qui la corruzione l'inefficienza
della macchina burocratica si sposano a
meraviglia quello vediamo una
correlazione fortissima tra inefficienza
burocratica e corruzione nei paesi
dell'unione europea e da ultimo
naturalmente la corruzione aumenta
quanto meno efficaci sono i controlli
tutti i tipi di controllo non solo
quelli penali a cui siamo abituati a
pensare ma anche quelli amministrativi
contabili sociali e politici
e allora non c'è da sorprendersi se
domini una sensazione per così dire da
liberi tutti i magistrati parlano di una
sindrome di impunità che sembra
affliggere protagonisti delle vicende di
corruzione perché di fatto a ben
guardare la corruzione in italia è
praticamente depenalizzata abbiamo 12
per cento di tangenti pagate vuol dire
almeno 45 milioni di episodi di
corruzione ma a questo si accompagna a
livello di procedimenti penali
circa mille persone denunciate e
all'incirca il dato lo mostra 300
persone condannate ogni anno di queste
300 persone condannate all 1,8 per cento
rischia di scontare a un solo giorno di
carcere
una vicenda che porta molto
probabilmente tra i due terre circa metà
due terzi dei procedimenti finiscono in
prescrizione quindi il nulla di fatto ma
non solo i funzionari corrotti non
vengono licenziati ma spesso fanno
carriera proprio perché come dire hanno
informazioni ricattatorie da utilizzare
non rivelare le malefatte altrui
i politici di norma sono ricandidati dai
loro partiti e rieletti in parlamento
oggi ne abbiamo circa il 10 per cento di
pregiudicati o imputati di varie di vari
reati non si parli di stigma o di
riprovazione sociale di danni alla
reputazione che dovrebbero derivare dal
coinvolgimento in questo tipo di vicende
meno per mai meno che mai per gli
imprenditori che diciamo su queste
vicende sembrano vivere una sorta di
limbo morale allora altra variabile per
quanto sia conveniente economicamente
non è detto che tutti siano pronti a
entrare in questo universo della
corruzione contano anche altre variabili
le variabili diciamo di ordine culturale
il tipo di valori che come dire
improntano le scelte dei dei funzionari
e dei cittadini ecco ci sono altri
modelli di analisi però purtroppo che si
concentrano su questi fattori ma
purtroppo anche guardando alla
corruzione in questa prospettiva il caso
italiano spicca come un caso anomalo e
studiando l'italia che un famoso
sociologo ha coniato il termine di
familismo amorale per descrivere proprio
una struttura di valori prevalenti nella
società che porta a
massimizzare la ricerca del vantaggio
materiale immediato per sé e per la
propria cerchia familiare ristretta
accompagnato dalla sfiducia verso
chiunque dichiari di perseguire un
interesse generale
ora potrà suscitare qualche sospetto
riguardo al familismo amorale che il mio
cognome vannucci sia lo stesso del
presentatore di questa giornata vi
lascio sul col dubbio se vi sia un
qualche mese un qualche legame che non
sia la mera coincidenza
appunto molti altri studi poi convergono
nel sottolineare che insomma questa
debolezza del senso civico caratterizza
ampie fasce della società italiana e in
qualche modo oppone deboli barriere al
loro coinvolgimento nella nella
corruzione
questo potrebbe forse bastare a spiegare
l'anomalia italiana ma c'è anche di
peggio
nella mia ricerca nel mio lavoro di
ricerca ho guardato in particolare a
come dire meccanismi di regolazione
interna della corruzione cioè lo studio
del caso italiano ci mostra proprio come
la corruzione possa certe condizioni
colonizzare del tutto alcuni centri di
spesa pubblica diventa per così dire il
motore della vita politica e
amministrativa
e allora in questo universo della
corruzione sistemica entrano in vigore
regole che sono alternative rispetto a
quelle dello stato e che detto nei
protagonisti della corruzione la gamma
di condotte accettabili a chi rivolgersi
quanto pagare cosa dire e naturalmente
anche cosa tacere come scongiurare
inconvenienti come marginali e punire
chi non sta al gioco e naturalmente come
calcolare e ripartire le tangenti e
spesso addirittura esiste anche un
governo della corruzione cioè ci sono
soggetti che scendono in campo in questo
mercato illegale
per garantire che le regole vengono
rispettate e punire chi non sta al gioco
questi soggetti sono diversi in alcuni
casi sono leader politici
faccendieri dei contatti trasversali
imprenditori alti dirigenti ministeriali
e spesso anche capofamiglia mafiosi come
mostra questo atlante della corruzione
europea le regioni di che conoscono
radicamento delle organizzazioni
criminali in italia alle quattro regioni
meridionali sono quelle che conoscono i
più alti livelli di corruzione
vado alle conclusioni un grande studioso
della democrazia atto che vi ha scritto
che non dobbiamo temere l'immoralità dei
grandi ma piuttosto la vista
dell'immoralità che conduce alla
grandezza e allora persino i 60 miliardi
di costo euro di euro annui di costo che
sono stimati dalla corte dei conti che
tutti citano diventano poca cosa di
fronte allo spettacolo di una classe
dirigente che ha fatto delle risorse
ricavate dalla corruzione la chiave per
la scalata nella loro cari e nella
carriera politica amministrativa e
imprenditoriale mentre quelli che
dicevano di no venivano sistematicamente
emarginati costretti al silenzio o alla
fuga e allora non perdiamo le speranze
in fondo il 21 dicembre di quest'anno il
mondo finiranno e quindi magari finirà
anche questo universo repellente della
produzione però se interveniamo sugli
stessi fattori che spiegano la
corruzione italiana il suo radicamento
possiamo anche modificarla in profondità
questa realtà ad esempio dobbiamo capire
che la propensione alla corruzione non è
iscritta nel patrimonio genetico la
svezia e paesi scandinavi
erano paesi che conosceva una corruzione
capillare fino alla fine dell'ottocento
e la stessa altri paesi singapore hong
kong
fino alla metà degli anni settanta del
novecento erano paesi estremamente
corrotti ma adesso tutti questi paesi
sono ai vertici delle classifiche del
dell'integrità perché perché sono state
applicate ha trovati applicate riforme
radicali buone leggi che hanno favorito
trasparenza e responsabilità dei
governanti
da un lato partecipazione coinvolgimento
dei cittadini dall'altro è lentamente in
quei paesi è mutata anche la struttura
sottostante dei valori sociali sono
cambiati i modelli culturali che
spingono all'onestà funzionari e
cittadini e allora per disinnescare i
meccanismi della corruzione sistemica
che caratterizza l'italia non è
necessario attendere l'intervento
dall'alto salvifico del legislatore che
da troppo tempo sta lì a tergiversare
con una legge che è un brodino inattuato
e tra l'altro con dentro molti i bocconi
avvelenati per così dire la classe
politica italiana su questo versante è
omertosa inadempiente per usare un
eufemismo da almeno vent'anni c'è un
ritardo che non potrà colmare in poco
tempo e allora per tutti i cittadini di
buona volontà forse è il caso di
cominciare a pensare a politiche e
strumenti di prevenzione della
corruzione che nascano dal basso ci sono
esperienze straordinarie in questo campo
le campagne avviate da libera e don
ciotti il codice etico promosso da
avviso pubblico un associazione di enti
locali contro le mafie che è stato già
adottato da decine di sindaci
amministratori e assessori e allora per
dare slancio a questa campagna è questa
politica anti corruzione dal basso qui
la speranza per il futuro il ruolo dei
giovani delle giovani generazioni è
decisivo perché la corruzione è stato
già detto deruba soprattutto loro
spoglia i giovani della speranza di un
ascesa sociale professionale fondata se
loro meriti costringe spesso alla
emigrazione non solo a fuggire i
cervelli i corpi ma spesso anche le le
coscienze c'è un dato inquietante col
quale come dire possiamo chiudere la
correlazione fortissima che esiste tra i
livelli di corruzione nei paesi europei
e la scarsa propensione delle imprese a
investire nell'innovazione nel
cambiamento nella ricerca sono convinto
che le barriere più forte la corruzione
italiana non possano nascere in
parlamento quelle barriere devono
consolidarsi credo all'interno della
società civile attraverso i valori che
ci trasmettiamo l'un l'altro esprimendo
i nostri giudizi morali e col nostro
esempio quotidiano perché in fondo il
valore di quello che possiamo ricavare
dalle nostre azioni non è misurabile
soltanto in termini monetari un euro
guadagnato impiegando le proprie
capacità per produrre beni e servizi che
come dire utili agli altri non allo
stesso valore di un euro che invece
viene ottenuto trafficando nell'ombra
pagando tangenti e depredando il bene
comune se riusciamo a far diventare
questo elementare messaggio vorrei dire
di coscienza civile un patrimonio comune
quale che sia il nostro ruolo sociale il
nostro credo politico persino la lotta
alla corruzione italiana non è senza
speranza e potremo aspirare a vivere nel
come nell'allegoria del lorenzetti nel
paradiso del buon governo grazie